as someone in media relations at the
moment do you sense like a real sort of
earthquake happening just related to how
we connect with our politicians how we
demand they connect with us how social
media has replaced Cable News in a lot
of ways just that everything really this
really does feel like to me four years
from now the election is gonna be
extremely different than this which will
probably be good for a lot of reasons
but this really does seem to be an
election taking place in two worlds the
traditional mainstream route and the
online world and they're just like
clashing and that's what's creating such
craziness yeah and I actually think
there are really three elections right
now there are those two there's sort of
cable world TV you know drama of the day
repeated all day long all day long on
cable TV then there's kind of the online
conversation that real people are having
with each other or ranting about with
each other right and then there's
actually the campaign that's out there
in the States
on the ground organizing where there is
real organizing particularly on the
Democratic side and the coffee shops and
in the town halls and community centers
and things like that where there really
is kind of old-fashioned shoe leather
vote targeting going on and it's rare
that those three you know campaigns have
come together in moments this this cycle
I think that the what's the so I I think
this notion of the citizen voice is
stronger than it's ever been and the
pushback on conventional wisdom I find
that reporters are most outraged and
freaked out of all the things that
happen in this campaign that thing that
reporters hate the most is this Donald
Trump like don't believe the media the
polls are rigged this is all crave the
media's bias like it's sort of the
attack on the media the undermining of
the media's the credit
source of information about the campaign
that has people the most crazy and in
some respects their reaction to it only
reinforces it because they spend a lot
of time then killing the message which
ends up appearing like they're killing
the messenger so a good example of that
was the what I thought was like a
ridiculous overwrought reaction to
Donald Trump saying he wasn't going to
accept the outcome of the election
mm-hmm
because I just thought this is stupid
you know of course he's gonna accept the
outcome of the election he's just he's
he's foaming at the mouth he's doing
what he does and but yet for three days
it was the headline what do you mean if
we say that it's over it's over
notice how can somebody say it's not
over when we say it's over you know
interesting it's interesting because
that line I actually thought was and I
led into the top of the show with this I
actually thought there was some
legitimacy legitimate scary stuff with
that because it's a dog whistle to his
people if he loses to say that it wasn't
us
it wasn't us but the system it's one
thing to say the media's messed up but
it's another thing to say that the
actual voting is rigged so I actually
did think that it was it had some cachet
were not I'm not giving a legitimacy I'm
just saying it had some like worth to
push back on yeah I understand but I
think of all things I think they're
gonna conflate whether or not the system
is rigged against them versus whether
people really believe that voting
machines have been hacked all right
those are two separate things yeah and I
don't I don't think that people will get
to voting machines have been hacked I
call me skeptical on that point but you
know the system is rigged the media is
biased regular people don't get a fair
shake your voice isn't represented I
mean that's Bernie Sanders - right
that's not just Donald Trump well that's
the funny thing they both were the
outsiders but okay so as someone that
does this that is a Democrat in media
relations and cable news and the whole
thing is it
fair to say that there are more
Democrats generally in media than there
are Republicans or conservatives there
are most of the people are liberal
that's that's fair to say right give me
a give me a meter relations answer come
on well I'm gonna split this up I think
what we have seen traditionally in the
Republican Party at their national
candidates and ever since kind of the
right-wing took over Republicans what
you end up having is sort of a real
split on social issues and I think that
there's no question of my experience in
them in the media world that there are
more sort of socially liberal people you
know media folks and there are socially
conservative media folks and so then
whenever candidates put emphasis there I
think that that has that has created
bias
I think the Trump issue though isn't
really about you know Democrats versus
conservatives I think it's just that
people are offended at how much he lies
I think people in the media are just
appalled at does the kind of you know
bad fact machine robot like person that
he is and and tries to encourage other
people to be and and and I think people
are just incensed by it and in the media
and so they're constantly pushing back
on him particularly in the last you know
six or eight weeks when it got more
serious and so but I don't I I don't
think that they'd be treating Mitt
Romney this way or I don't I don't think
they'd be treating Marco Rubio this way
I think this is unique to Donald Trump
yeah but really I mean with with Romney
you know there was the binders of women
and the 47% like you don't think at this
point they breed pretty much were saying
Romney was anti woman at this point so
isn't it just that's sort of what the
Republican is gonna get like I think a
lot of people are looking
back and going man maybe we should have
been a little nicer to MIT because look
at this yeah I'm not sure the binders of
women was as much a media thing as an
effective echo that the Obama campaign
made happen but I you know so most of my
reporter friends honestly don't vote and
is that out of principle or laziness you
know that they find that important so I
I actually don't but do i experience
them as generally socially more
progressive and yes but also you know I
do think there's this path of socially
progressive fiscally conservative if
there were a candidate down those down
that middle path you know you'd find a
lot of media more apt to be there yeah
well I think that that's where most of
the country is I think they're fiscally
conservative if they really understood
economics and I think they're for the
most part but obviously not the fringes
are socially liberal but I'm curious as
someone that's been in this for a long
time and you're you're in the the DC
crowd and the media crowd and all that
stuff in the crowd you're enduring the
crowd you're very you're very popular
amongst the popular people that are in
DC Liza what what do you think about the
the sort of level of friendliness in
general between the media and the
politicians I mean you know we could
look at any cable network and the amount
of people that are considered analysts
that either work on campaigns or have
worked on campaigns or who are actively
working on super PACs I don't even need
to name the people so I won't put you on
the spot but there's plenty of people
that then leave there to go work for the
DNC or work but like it's just this big
orgy and and people I think are really
legitimately sick of that so as someone
that has a little insight into that how
do we how should the average person view
that I think and you know when I I've
been at MSNBC and CNBC and CNN so those
my experience but I
that the network in some respects looks
at people like us as chief talent and
then there's a lot of free talent
because there are a lot of people who
you know come on with expertise for for
free and I thank God you said that
because every time I've gone on HL and
they never pay me and I thought maybe it
was just me but I do think you know that
that producers and Booker's try and look
for people to come on these shows that
bring something to the table and I don't
think that it's a disqualifier that one
of the things that they also bring to
the table is having been having been in
the room and that sometimes they're
still in the room you know the room
where it happens and so I think that
that's something that viewers have
historically been interested in from a
nap you know an analyst point of view
but I I do think that it has the
potential to turn into kind of a feeling
of coziness that there is a there's a
room where things happen for people who
are invited into the room and if you're
not invited into the room you get
screwed and I think that that's why you
know like like I think it's CNN we have
anchors like you know frankly Anderson
Cooper Jake Tapper people who don't see
themselves as particularly political and
will ask people questions like regular
people talk and so I I think that's
really important I think that we can be
on TV interpreting what's happening in
the election for people who don't live
it day in and day out in Turk what does
that mean if the poll says this and one
stayed in a poll in another state how do
you reconcile that and how am I
a campaign make a decision about where
to disperse resources so people like me
can bring that kind of expertise to the
table and then people like me can argue
on behalf of a candidate and trash
another one right so we're going to
bring those two things but I'm not going
to pretend to know details about the job
search of a laid-off factory worker in
Ohio I'm you know I'm I have empathy for
it I want to see good public policy
about it but I'm gonna depend on CNN to
go to Ohio and and find ways for those
people to talk for themselves and to
find it like real representatives for it
yeah do you think part of that part of
the problem is just a human reaction
like once you're invited to those
parties I always think the White House
Correspondents Dinner I used to be
friends with someone in a public person
I don't have to mention him who would
rail against it he thought it was the
worst thing ever you see the media is in
bed with the administration and they
hate it and hated it and then last year
got invited to it now he's all about it
so right so that there's some element of
it's almost like the the powers that be
can kind of invite you in and everybody
wants to go to the cool part you know
they call it the nerd prom which sounds
so douchey and me but like they you know
they want they know ah you got into the
party once you're around these people
you enjoy the good food and the
cocktails like you're gonna ease up a
little bit it's just natural human
reaction do you think that's there do
you think that's a fair estimation I
know not for everybody but I think for a
certain amount of the reporters that are
around that it's like you want to be in
the club look I'll just take Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton as an example
I don't think either one of these have
had reporters this year ease up on
either one I think part of it is timing
Hillary had a really rough year and a
half this last six or eight weeks people
have said all right we've had a really
we really dissected her and gone off on
the emails and
on the Benghazi and unlike everything
and now we're they're still going after
her on Wikileaks and and other things
but Donald Trump had had a you know by a
lot of media accounts a good skate there
for a while and so now he's getting you
know his rectal exam and and I think in
some respects it's it's a timing issue
that people are paying attention now in
a way that they didn't pay attention
before but I do not think either one of
these candidates feel like the press has
been cozy with them and I think if you
look at House and Senate candidates or
local candidates that are subjected to
maybe end up there's been less emphasis
in the media on some of those other
races because the presidential election
is such a you know car accident that you
can't you know take your eyes off of it
yeah but so I think maybe on some of
those races there's less focus and there
needs to be but I don't see this as kind
of a clear sale for either of these
folks
you